Et si c'était quelqu'un qui l'avait tuée ?
Genre qui ?
Je sais pas. Y a peut-être un tueur au Vortex.
Un serial killer même.
Ce serait trop stylé en vrai, moi j'adore les serial killers.
Moi aussi j'aime beaucoup ça, c'est qui ton préf ? Moi j'avoue j'aime...
Nan mais ça va pas ? C'est des gens qui tuent d'autres personnes !
Enfin j'sais pas, un peu d'humanité quoi !
Et puis pensez à Valentine.
Nan mais, j'avoue, moi aussi ils me fascinent.
Je sais pas, je dois être un peu bizarre.
Mais nan, ils nous fascinent tous Valentine.
Le serial killer ne fait pas que tuer...
Il fait vendre !
Quoi qu'on en dise, Ted Bundy, Ed Kemper et consors ont malheureusement été élevé au rang d'icônes des années 70
et ont fortement influencé la culture populaire américaine.
On peut trouver aux Etats-Unis du merchandising à leur effigie, et des objets leur ayant appartenu se vendent parfois à prix d'or.
Et je ne vous parle pas des centaines de lettres que les tueurs en série reçoivent en prison de la part de leurs fans, quand ils ne se marient pas tout simplement avec elles.
Sans eux il est très probable que tout un pan de l'imaginaire de fiction n'existerait pas.
Qu'il s'agisse du Silence des Agneaux, Se7en ou encore American Psycho,
les films et séries qui ont été inspiré par les tueurs en série se comptent par milliers selon IMDB et un bonne partie d'entre eux sont devenus cultes.
C'est assez cocasse, quand on sait que l'inventeur de l'expression « serial killer », l'agent spécial Robert Ressler du FBI,
qui a inspiré Bill Tench dans la série MindHunter,
aurait trouvé ce terme en référence aux « Serials »,
les fameux feuilletons qui étaient diffusés semaine après semaine en première partie des long-métrages dans les salles de cinéma et qui avaient beaucoup de succès à l'époque.
Mais comment expliquer ce "star system du mal" et leur influence toujours si forte dans la pop culture actuelle alors que tout ça va totalement à l'encontre de toutes les normes morales,
sociales et légales que l'on nous inculque depuis notre naissance ?
Eh ben peut-être parce que bons nombres de tueurs souhaitaient au plus profond d'eux-même devenir ces icônes
et qu'à cause d'une forme de fascination macabre au plus profond de nous-même, nous les y avons aidé.
Pour la criminologue Lygia Négrier-Dormont, le tueur en série est souvent un psychopathe motivé par un désir narcissique d'exercer un pouvoir extrême de vie et de mort,
semblable aux pouvoirs des Forces Supérieures, tel Dieu.
C'est là qu'en tant que criminel, on a un paradoxe.
Certains d'entre eux ont envie de poursuivre leurs crimes sans se faire prendre,
mais en même temps il y a une grande frustration de ne pas être reconnu pour ce qui est pour eux « l' œuvre de leur vie ».
Et selon David Schmid, un chercheur américain spécialiste de la question,
nous exauçons le souhait de reconnaissance de ces tueurs en faisant d'eux de véritables célébrités
par la fascination qu’ils exercent sur nous.
Alors que l'on a tendance à croire que la célébrité va aux méritants et aux talentueux, la vérité est tout autre.
La célébrité est simplement synonyme de présence sur la scène médiatique.
Et malheureusement, plus un crime est horrible, plus les médias en parlent, plus l'auteur de ces crimes sera médiatisé,
plus l'intérêt qui lui sera porté par le public sera fort,
plus la demande d'en entendre parler à nouveau sera grande,
plus il marquera les esprits, plus il s'installera dans la culture populaire,
plus il influencera des œuvres de fiction, plus ces œuvres auront du succès, etc, etc.
Il suffit donc de marquer les esprits, peu importe que ça soit en bien ou en mal.
C'est pour cela que Charles Manson a eu sa place sur les couvertures de Life Magazine, au même titre que Maryline Monroe auparavant.
Assoiffé de célébrité et n'arrivant pas à réaliser son rêve de percer dans la musique, il usa de son influence naturelle pour devenir un gourou,
et ensuite un tueur en série par procuration, vu qu'il n'aurait apparemment tué personne de ses mains.
Et s'il a tant marqué les esprits, c'est parce qu'il s'est approprié les codes de la culture hippie, pour y mettre définitivement un terme et marquer la fin de l'insouciance et du peace and love des années 60
en devenant au début des années 70 ce qu’on pourrait appeler une contre-icône.
Les tueurs en série sont donc par définition des personnages publiques, et qui dit “personnage publiques”, dit "personal branding".
En gros, le personal branding, ou marketing personnel ou de soi-même, consiste à considérer une personne comme une marque
et le marketer comme on markete un produit ou un service.
Et si je vous dit ça, c'est parce que pour mieux comprendre notre fascination pour les tueurs en série et leur influence dans la culture populaire,
je vous propose de les analyser sous un angle marketing
afin de vous montrer pourquoi le serial killer a tout d'une marque à succès !
Et pour ça on va utiliser le prisme d'identité de la marque.
Le prisme de l'identité de marque a été développé par Jean-Noël Kapferer en 1992.
Ce prisme consiste à dépeindre l'identité d'une marque, dans ce cas -ci le tueur, et sa projection vers le consommateur, dans ce cas-ci nous,
afin d'analyser le rapport qu'il y a entre les deux.
Ce prisme se compose de 6 faces.
D'un côté le physique, la personnalité et les valeurs de la marque.
De l’autre côté la relation qu'il y a entre elle et le consommateur, le ressenti interne de ce dernier, et l'image qu'il dégage via le rapport qu'il entretient avec cette marque.
Mais avant de comprendre comment les serial killers sont devenus des influenceurs, il faut qu'on soit sûr de quoi on parle précisément quand on dit « Serial Killer ».
Tu vois, la criminologie, ce n'est pas vraiment du droit en fait.
C'est un truc qui est pluridisciplinaire en fait, on ne voit pas que du droit.
Du coup, moi, ce n'est pas un truc que j'ai étudié.
Mais c'est quand même super intéressant, parce que tueur en série, ce n'est pas vraiment une définition juridique.
Tu ne le retrouves pas dans le code pénal par exemple.
C'est vraiment, des psychiatres ou
des psychanalystes ou je ne sais quoi qui vont poser ce mot-là.
Nous, en droit, on ne va pas parler de tueur en série.
Mais du coup, il n'y a aucun moyen de définir ce qu'est un serial killer précisément.
Si, il y a tout de même des gens qui ont essayé de le définir.
Notamment, il faut avoir fait plusieurs crimes dans un espace de temps assez défini.
Et généralement, ce qu'on remarque, c'est que les tueurs en série ne connaissent pas leurs victimes.
Quand tu es une femme, tu as plus de chance d'être violentée sexuellement ou tuée par quelqu'un que tu connais.
Là, les tueurs en série, ils choisissent souvent des victimes qu'ils ne connaissent pas du tout.
Ca veut dire qu'ils n'en veulent pas à la personne particulièrement, c'est plus parce là, c'est une proie idéale, ce genre de choses.
Et du coup ce qui est compliqué, c'est que comme il n'y a pas de lien entre la victime et le tueur.
C'est comment est-ce que tu mets la main sur le tueur ?
Il y a des agents du FBI qui ont essayé de faire un portrait
pour voir un petit peu le profilage de la personne en question.
Comme dans la série Mindhunter du coup ?
Exactement, c'est plutôt bien foutu dans cette série.
Et du coup, c'est pour essayer de voir un petit peu s'il a une signature,
est-ce qu'il a un mode opératoire très particulier,
est-ce que les victimes ont toujours le même profil, et tout ça.
Mais c'est un exercice qui est très très complexe.
Du coup, il n'y a pas d'existence légale dans le code pénal français du tueur en série.
On ne va pas dire telle personne, t'es condamnée à tant parce que tu es un tueur en série.
Par contre, on a 150 cas qui pourrait rentrer dans cette définition.
Qui correspondent aux caractéristiques de pas connaître la personne,...
- Nan après ce qui me saoule, c'est qu'on les qualifie toujours de monstre en fait.
- Ah mais c'est des monstres ! C'est pour ça !
En fait, tu les déshumanise en faisant ça.
On ne s'interroge jamais du pourquoi ils ont fait ça.
C'est quoi leur profil, qu'est-ce qu'ils ont vécu dans leur enfance.
Tout ça expliquera mais ça reste des monstres, c'est aussi ça qui les rend iconiques et cool.
Nan mais c'est pas des stars du Rock non plus !
Le premier point est l'aspect physique : ce qui est tangible, ce que l'on peut voir.
Pour une marque, il s'agira de son logo ou son packaging par exemple.
Selon les statistiques des auteurs français Senninger, Hiegel et Kahn.
Les femmes représentent seulement 5 à 10 % des tueurs en série,
entre 73 et 84 % de ces criminels sont de type caucasien
et 60% d'entre eux avaient moins de trente ans lorsqu'ils ont commis leur premier crime.
Notre archétype de tueur en série est donc un mâle blanc de moins de 30 ans et ne se distingue pas au niveau physique.
Il peut donc mener une vie normale : aller bruncher, jouer à la pétanque ou que sais-je.
Quand un tueur sévit mais n'a pas encore été attrapé, les médias vont lui attribuer un surnom.
Et ça, ça lui donne un côté « super vilain », ce qui le rend déjà iconique
avant même que l'on ne connaisse sa réelle identité.
L'Ogre de Santa Cruz ou le Dévisseur de têtes pour Ed Kemper, le LadyKiller pour Ted Bundy,
ou tout simplement ce bon vieux Jack l'éventreur !
Ce surnom est souvent basé sur ce qu'on appelle la signature du tueur.
Parce que pour un tueur, la signature, c'est ce qui fait que le meurtre est différent d'un autre,
ce qui le rend unique et qui est reproduit à chaque fois.
C’est un acte compulsif, ancrée dans la nature profonde du tueur, quelque chose qu'il ne peut s'empêcher de faire et qui est en partie inconscient.
C'est d'ailleurs souvent ce qui trahit un tueur, car elle permet à la police de connecter les crimes entre eux.
Les tueurs en série sont réputés pour être très charismatique.
Ce stéréotype a évidemment influencé la fiction,
que ce soit Anthony Hopkins ou Mads Mikkelsen pour Hannibal, Kevin Spacey dans Se7en, ou encore Christian Bale dans American Psycho.
Bien qu’il ne s’agisse pas d’une généralité, ça ne vient pas de nulle part.
Le procureur Vincent Bugliosi, en charge du dossier Charles Manson, décrivait qu'il avait une aura indéfinissable.
Où qu'il aille, les gens gravitaient autour de lui, et c'est pour ça qu’on le considérait avant tout comme un gourou.
Et quand ils ne sont pas juste charismatique, ils sont carrément BG.
Comme Ted Bundy, tellement beau-parleur, élégant et charismatique, qu'il faisait rire l'auditoire pendant son procès
et n'hésitait pas à faire des clins d'oeil à la caméra.
A l'époque, de nombreuses femmes refusaient de le reconnaître coupable à cause de son physique avantageux.
Comme l'expliquait Emily Tibbatts, autrice et spécialiste des tueurs en série : il n'avait pas la tête de l'emploi.
On se figure les tueurs comme laids, méchants et affreux,
et si l’un d’entre eux est beau, on va se dire qu’il ne peut pas réellement commettre des actes monstrueux.
Cela est dû à un biais cognitif appelé « Effet de halo » qui fait qu'on perçoit de manière sélective des informations allant dans le sens d'une première impression.
En gros, une caractéristique jugée positive à propos d'une personne a tendance à rendre plus positives les autres caractéristiques, même si on ne les connaît pas.
C'est pour cette raison que l’interprète de Ted Bundy dans l'adaptation Netflix est Zac Efron,
un choix controversé car l'acteur, jugé trop BG pour le rôle,
aurait tendance à glorifier le tristement célèbre tueur en série.
Un choix pourtant pertinent puisque bien avant cela, lors de la sortie d'un simple documentaire montrant le vrai Ted Bundy,
on avait pu voir des femmes sur Twitter dire : «Ted Bundy est vraiment mignon.».
- Ah bah carrément !
- Ah !
Netflix avait d'ailleurs publiquement réagit sur Twitter avec :
« Nous avons vu passer beaucoup de discussions sur le prétendu sex-appeal de Ted Bundy et nous voudrions gentiment rappeler à tout le monde qu’il y a littéralement
des MILLIERS d’hommes sexy sur la plateforme, dont la plupart n’ont pas été reconnus coupables de meurtres en série ».
Autre cas, malgré la communication de la série “You” mettant en avant que le personnage est dangereux,
beaucoup de jeunes femmes considèrent la série comme « romantique ».
L'acteur Penn Badgley a même réagit sur Twitter en rappelant bien qu'il interprète un meurtrier.
Je me demande si ça pourrait être Florence.
Elles se sont pris la tête quand Shirley a du signer le bail.
Faut dire que Shirley n'avait pas été très coopérative.
Nan mais c'est n'importe quand ce contrat il faut tout reprendre !
Toutes les choses a modifié ! Dans ce pays, il y a quand même des lois,
si on ne les respecte pas, c'est la fin du monde civilisé.
Non mais signe pas n'importe quoi, il faut tout modifier là.
Sacré Shirley !
Ça va, Florence s'en remettra.
C'est un mobile en tout cas, les femmes aiment bien le poison, je crois.
Peut-être qu'elle a fait son coup avant la soirée.
Cependant il est important de noter que l'archétype du tueur en série beau et charmeur est largement exagéré
et ne représente bien entendu pas la majorité des cas.
Du coup, on va parler de la personnalité.
Dans le cas d'une marque, elle détermine son tone of voice, son comportement, son attitude, c'est ce qu'elle dit,
comment elle le dit et ce qu'elle fait.
Cela va essentiellement déterminer la façon dont elle va communiquer dans ses publicités.
Dans notre cas, un tueur en série est souvent un psychopathe avec un manque d'empathie et un certain sadisme,
mais ce qui les caractérise, c'est l'ambivalence affective.
Le fait qu il ait un « moi » social et innocent qui puisse cohabiter avec l'envie meurtrière qu'il a au fond de lui.
Les tueurs en série dissimulent une envie insatiable de crimes qui mêlent souvent sexe et mort,
et surtout un plaisir qu'il tire de ses actes par un sentiment très fort de supériorité.
Comme nous l'avons dit plus tôt, il a généralement une personnalité narcissique.
Dennis Rader se surnommait lui même BTK en référence à son mode opératoire
et entretenait des relations épistolaires avec la police et la presse,
démontrant chez lui un profond narcissisme et un besoin manifeste de célébrité.
C'est d'ailleurs ce jeu de supériorité avec la police qui a causé sa perte.
Nous pouvons également parler tueur du zodiaque, qui lui ne s'est jamais fait attrapé,
alors qu'il gérait une véritable stratégie de communication qui consistait à envoyer des lettres à la presse,
incluant quatres cryptogrammes, dont 3 n'ont à ce jour pas été élucidés.
Selon la pédopsychiatre Catherine Jousselme, c’est ce genre de choses qui ont influencé la manière de présenter les tueurs dans la fiction,
qui fait passer ces psychopathes pour des gens intelligents, brillants, très forts.
Ils semblent supérieurs d'une certaine façon au commun des mortels.
Et même s'il faut noter que par exemple Ed Kemper avait un QI supérieur à celui d'Einstein, dans la majorité des cas, la réalité est tout autre.
L'archétype du tueur en série ultra-intelligent n’est pas si courant.
On peut justement voir dans la série MindHunter que les agents du FBI sont presque déçus de voir que le tueur William Pierce
est, en réalité, très peu intelligent.
En effet, dans certains cas plus rares, le tueur en série peut présenter un profil psychotique, plutôt que psychopathe.
Une minorité atteinte de troubles mentaux tels que la schizophrénie, sont des psychotiques compulsifs,
qui tuent de façon impulsive et désorganisée, mais sont quand même considérés comme des tueurs en série.
Le psychotique désorganisé aura une intelligence moyenne,
une instabilité professionnelle et mentale,
sera socialement immature,
improvisera son crime et paniquera durant l'acte.
C'est pourquoi la distinction la plus répandue faite par l'unité des sciences du comportement du FBI
se situe entre « tueur organisé » et « tueur désorganisé ».
Par exemple, le Joker de Heath Ledger dans la trilogie de Nolan s'apparente au tueur psychopathe,
tandis que le Joker de Joaquin Phoenix du film de Todd Philipps s'apparente plutôt au tueur psychotique.
Les raisons de leurs personnalités complexes sont multifactorielles,
il n’existe pas d’élément qui explique systématiquement qu’est ce qui les a fait basculer dans la violence,
même s'il a été constaté que 90% des tueurs en série ont subi dans l'enfance des sévices sexuels ou des violences physiques ou morales.
Et là on arrive à un élément important du marketing : le storytelling.
Le storytelling est une méthode de communication qui se base sur une structure narrative,
qui emprunte aux contes et aux récits pour générer de l'émotion.
Mettre en avant un passé tragique, une fêlure en lui qui raconte une histoire dans laquelle tout le monde peut se reconnaître
afin d'expliquer un comportement déviant,
est un moyen utilisé dans la fiction pour créer de l'empathie pour un tueur,
le rendre presque attachant et excusable.
Même dans le cas où une fiction est tirée de la réalité,
elle est romancée pour qu'un maximum de personnes puissent se l'approprier et se mettre à la place du tueur.
Ainsi, la fiction ne fait qu'amplifier la fascination qui entoure les tueurs en série.
Tout ça permet donc de créer un personnage de fiction bien écrit,
mais c'est également fréquemment utilisé par les vrais tueurs en série, qui se présentent très souvent comme des victimes à leurs interlocuteurs.
C’est une manière pour eux de se déresponsabiliser de leurs actes.
Ou alors, c'est Un Créatif.
Le simple fait qu'il se serve de la mort de ma cousine pour faire son premier épisode de cette saison, c'est un alibi.
Et il s'entendait mal avec Shirley, je crois.
De toutes façons, tu t'y connais en incrust' toi.
Dis, Shirley, c'est toi qui vient d'aller chier là, t'aurais pu passer la brosse ou un truc comme ça.
Eh vous connaissez la différence entre Shirley et un rat mort ?
C'est pas l'odeur en tout cas.
Mais je ne sais pas si ça colle avec qui il est au fond.
Toute marque a des valeurs piliers qui lui permette de s'ancrer dans le réel.
Comme pour n'importe quel être humain, on a tous des choses dans lesquelles on croit.
C'est d'ailleurs l'élément qui va faire qu'une marque est  durable ou non.
Ces valeurs évoluent avec le temps pour être en accord avec la société afin que le consommateur s'y retrouve.
Ce qui est si intriguant dans les cas des tueurs en série, c'est qu'il n'y en a pas.
Il n'y a aucune valeur.
OK, le serial killer incarne aujourd'hui le mal à l'état pur.
Mais est-ce réellement une valeur en soi ?
Même si c'était le cas, elle est justement en opposition avec la société,
et personne n'est supposé s'y retrouver.
Le problème c’est que le tueur en série ne tue généralement pas par idéologie, par fanatisme, et pas non plus par appât du gain.
Le seul moteur du tueur en série est fréquemment le sentiment de toute-puissance que lui procurent ses crimes.
On peut voir que dans le film « Joker », le protagoniste lance malgré lui un mouvement de foule empreint de nombreuses valeurs relatives à la lutte des classes.
Sauf que lui n'a pas choisi ces valeurs, c'est la foule qui lui a attribué.
Lui est davantage comblé par la reconnaissance qu'on lui donne, et le pouvoir qu'il en obtient.
Et le pouvoir peut être une motivation, mais pas une valeur en soi.
En bref, pour beaucoup de psychiatres, psychologues et criminologues, les tueurs en série savent très bien ce qu'ils veulent faire,
mais il ne savent pas vraiment plus que nous pourquoi ils le font.
Et c'est sans doute cette envie de les comprendre qui crée ce rapport à la fois si flou et si particulier que l'on peut avoir avec eux.
Monté, je ne sais pas, ma cousine l'aimait bien.
Peut-être un peu trop, c'est vrai.
Qu'est-ce que tu branles dans mon lit ?
Allez viens mon loulou !
Je sais que sous l'ours se cache un cœur de pigeon.
Putain, Valentine, y a encore ta cousine qui a pété une durite.
Ça te dirait pas qu'on lui prenne un billet pour Valencienne ou Bar-Le-Duc, histoire qu'on n'en parle plus.
Après, je ne sais pas si c'est un mobile.
Elle ne lui a pas fait le coup plus de 4 ou 5 fois.
Il y a toujours une relation qui connecte une marque et un consommateur,
il s'agit du niveau d'affection, de passion qu'il y a entre les deux.
Elle détermine à quel point le consommateur est prêt à recommander une marque.
Ça peut être basé sur une relation de confiance par exemple.
Mais au travers des canaux de communication que sont les médias, quelle type de relation entretenons-nous avec ces tueurs,
nous, citoyens lambdas ?
Et bien pour revenir à l'importance du storytelling, les médias ont en quelque sorte remplacé les livres de notre enfance.
Les tueurs en série sont des monstres modernes.
C'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'Hollywood s'empare des serial killers.
Des méchants basés sur des histoires à la fois vraies et hors du commun,
une figure du mal à la personnalité complexe,
qui justifie que le héros le combatte,
c'est manichéen et c'est clair.
C’est d’ailleurs comme dans la réalité. .es profilers n'existent que parce que les serial killers existent.
Et lorsque le tueur est carrément le personnage principal de l'histoire, on parlera d'anti-héros plutôt que de méchant.
Ça mène à ce que l’on appelle le « syndrôme Hannibal Lecter ».
On s'identifie davantage au tueur qu'à ses victimes.
Et comme nous l'avons dit, nous ne savons pas précisément pourquoi le serial killer agit comme ça.
C'est donc cette tache aveugle dans son psyché, que l'on va tenter de remplir avec nos explications et nos fantasmes.
On a besoin de lui donner des raisons, on veut savoir pourquoi.
En psychologie, on appelle ça la projection.
Chercher à comprendre n'empêche ainsi pas de condamner les actes commis.
L'attrait tient ainsi plus d'une volonté d'éprouver de l'empathie.
Voilà donc le type de relation que l’on entretient avec les tueurs, mais pourquoi ?
Qu'est-ce que tout cela nous fait ressentir ? Quelle image ça nous renvoie de nous-même ?
Les émotions véhiculées par une marque facilite la mémoire.
En effet, les gens se souviennent davantage de ce qu'on leur fait ressentir que ce qu'on leur dit.
Une marque aura toujours un effet sur une personne au travers de ce qu'elle lui propose,
comme par exemple, la sensation d'appartenir à une communauté en achetant tel produit.
Et c’est les ressentis que les tueurs provoquent chez nous qui expliqueraient notre fascination.
Tout d’abord, selon le psychiatre Christophe André,
la peur est un système d'alarme nécessaire à notre survie et il est nécessaire qu'il reste bien réglé.
C'est sans doute pour ça que l'on aime se faire peur,
mais bien sûr, uniquement dans des conditions sécurisées devant une fiction mettant en scène un tueur en série.
Mais ce n'est pas tout, parce que les tueurs en série, qui sont par nature des personnes qui font le mal,
nous reconditionne sur le manichéisme de la société avec une vision dichotomique du bien et du mal.
Le chercheur américain David Schmid explique dans son livre «Natural Born Celebrity : Serial Killers in American Culture »
que la fascination pour les criminels, qui sont des personnes anormales et ne répondant pas aux codes de la société,
permet de se rassurer sur sa propre normalité et de se confirmer
"Je ne suis pas comme eux, donc je suis quelqu'un de bien".
Si le meurtrier fascine, c'est donc avant tout parce que comprendre son anormalité
permettrait de se rassurer sur sa propre normalité.
Être fasciné par les tueurs en série est donc tout ce qu'il y a de plus sain, ne pas s'y intéresser du tout serait presque en fait...
plus inquiétant.
Dans le cas d'une marque, le reflet est l'image que le consommateur renvoie aux autres en s'appropriant cette marque.
Par exemple, une marque de chaussure sportive donnera à son entourage l'impression qu'on est sportif.
Cela contribue notamment au statut social.
Mais que nous donne comme image d'aimer les serial killers ? Celle de quelqu'un de cool et edgy ou celle d'un détraqué admirateur de meurtre ?
Aucun des deux vu qu'il s'agit en fait de quelque chose de tout à fait humain.
S'intéresser aux tueurs en série est normal
parce que nous sommes capables de séparer la fiction de la réalité.
Le problème, c'est quand on ne fait pas la distinction et qu'on entre dans l'excès.
Il existe par exemple des collections privées dans lesquelles on peut trouver des objets et des œuvres ayant appartenu où dont les auteurs sont des tueurs en série.
Il s'agit d'enregistrement de chansons de Charles Manson, ou encore des peintures faites par John Wayne Gacy, le clown tueur.
On peut également y trouver des dessins de crânes par Richard Ramirez, condamné à mort pour avoir tué et violé plus d'une dizaine de femmes.
Certains sites proposent des ventes aux enchères, il est par exemple possible d'acheter pour 800 dollars un burrito que Charles Manson n'avait pas terminé dans sa cellule.
Ce business du morbide quelque peu déplacé s'appelle « Murderabilia ».
Des pèlerinages sont également organisés sur des lieux où certains crimes ont été commis,
et ce trop plein de fascination peut monter jusqu'à rentrer dans le domaine de la pathologie, là où la passion devient l'attirance.
Cela s'appelle l'hybristophilie (ou syndrome de Bonnie et Clyde),
soit le fait d'être attiré sexuellement par un individu ayant commis un crime.
La pathologie n'est pas rare, et les tueurs les plus célèbres entretiennent régulièrement des relations épistolaires romantiques depuis leur prison,
allant jusqu'à se marier avec leurs fans.
Comme c'est le cas pour Charles Manson, qui était marié à une femme de 26 ans depuis sa prison peu avant sa mort à 83 ans en 2017.
La journaliste Isabelle Horlans a même interviewé dans son livre « L'amour (fou) pour un criminel » des « killers groupies »,
des véritables communauté de fans hardcore de Serial Killer sur les réseaux sociaux,
et les témoignages font froid dans le dos.
Si cette fascination est ce qui fait de nous des humains, et que s'y intéresser à ce sujet ne veut pas dire l'encourager,
il est tout de même important de rappeler qu'il y a une limite entre la fascination saine et l'admiration malsaine envers les tueurs en série.
En bref, le serial killer a bon avoir tous les traits de la marque à succès, le mieux, c'est tout simplement de se contenter de regarder des films.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, si vous l'avez apprécié n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l'air,
à vous abonner, à activer la cloche, à commenter, partager.
Et si vous voulez en parler, vous pouvez nous rejoindre sur le Discord du Vortex.
Peut-être qu'elle est juste morte de dire finalement.
C'est nul mais bon.
Oui, et puis surtout, personne n'y croira jamais.
De toutes façons, on va aller à la police ?
Nan mais nan, on va nous accuser.
Moi déjà, j'ai des épisodes à écrire.
Je dois aller en convention ce week-end.
Ça ne m'arrange pas vraiment d'être suspecté dans une affaire où il y a un mort.
Oui en plus c'est un peu louche d'avoir un cadavre sur le canapé depuis deux jours.
Le chien commence à tourner autour.
Vous déconnez là ? On ne va pas aller à la police ?
Moi je propose la démocratie, et le statu quo en cas d'égalité, voilà.
Vous êtes d'accord avec ça ? Levez la main si vous êtes d'accord avec ça.
Et qui vote pour qu'on ne le dise pas ?
Vous déconnez là en fait.
On ne va pas aller à la police.
Vous savez que c'est une obligation légale en fait d'aller à la police quand on a un cadavre sur les bras ?
Vous voulez qu'on soit complice ?
Vous voulez que notre carrière elle soit foutue à cause d'une erreur ?
Ah oui et si vous voulez qu'on parle
d'avantage de serial killers tout ça
je suis à la sortie de cette vidéo en ce moment même
en live sur ma chaine Twitch, le lien s'affiche juste là ou alors il est dans la description.
Bref, venez maintenant,
ça va être... mortel !